after four seasons and the numerable
betrayals the succeeding CEO of Ray star
Roy Co has finally been revealed but
could the end of the show have been
under our noses the whole time since
succession began the question on viewers
Minds is who would ultimately carry on
the way star royco Legacy after family
patriarch Logan Roy inevitably had to
step down turns out the mighty CEO
stepped down sooner than anticipated as
Logan died in the third episode of
season four since that point it's been a
Mad Dash to acquire power among the
Roy's siblings and the series finale
with open eyes finally brought things to
a close the only way it was possible Tom
wamsganz ultimately receives an offer to
become CEO which the Roy siblings try to
circumnavigate however at the last
second Tom's wife shiv sides with her
husband or against her brother Kendall
depending on how you look at it allowing
Tom to acquire the position throughout
the run of the show there were various
fan theories suggesting Tom would end up
Victorious over the Roy children after
all Logan appeared to take a real shine
to him throughout the series he even
caused Tom's son at one point albeit at
the time when he was not entirely Lucid
however one theory that came out just
before the finale aired suggests the
answer was right before our eyes the
whole time whether the showrunners
realized it or not names and prestigious
TV shows tend to carry additional
meaning in succession the last name Roy
literally translates to King so it's
easy to see the symbolism there
additionally Tom's wife goes by the
nickname Schiff meaning knife which is
appropriate for someone who's not above
using underhandedness to get away even
in the series finale one could argue she
stabbed her brother in the back so that
her husband will become CEO however the
last name wormsgan should have told
everyone what to expect from the moment
he was introduced Sophie Kim the
editor-in-chief and Nameberry posted a
tick tock a few days before the finale
offering a significant hint why Tom
would be the new CEO working for
Nameberry she naturally points to her
names of meaning and while warmsgans
isn't significant on its own it does tie
some to someone who would mirror his own
arc baseball player Bill wormsguns more
the real life after Lee is spelled
slightly different from the erratic head
of ATN with two s's at the end instead
of one bill did something some would
achieve in a different context in The
Tick Tock Kim explains that one scans
was a baseball player best known for
being the only player in history to
complete an unassist triple play during
a World Series game in a baseball game a
triple player occurs when all three outs
are recorded and one single swing of the
bat it's incredibly rare to be done by
one single Fielder hence the term
unassisted triple play it's only been
done 15 times throughout the Sport's
history and wamscans did it during
baseball's equivalent of a series finale
in the succession finale Tom achieves a
similar feat by knocking down all three
Roy siblings out of contention for CEO
at once sure you should probably know
it's me he even bested Kendall's attempt
to subvert his Ascension with the final
vote coming down to shift we may or may
not have considered Tom to be a better
CEO than her brother either way she had
to stop Kendall's rise Tom's Journey to
the top spot can be charted back to the
season 3 finale when he ratted out all
three voice siblings to Logan making a
play that cut all three out of the
running as Kim explains it's important
to make a note of unusual surnames in
film and television mom's Gans always
stood out but even though it matches his
character Arc perfectly executive
producer Frank Rich told slate I hate to
spoil the internet's fun but it's false
Tom's family name was picked before he
had shot a first season he went on to
mention how many writers for the show
are British and therefore likely
wouldn't be up to date with obscure
American baseball names it just so
happens to be one of the biggest
coincidences in TV history
foreign